okay hello everyone
uh wait a minute i'm not seeing what i'm
expecting to see here
oh dear hold on one second
well
uh hello to people joining the live
stream we are doing a wolfram language
design review part of our incremental
language development
program and we have a variety of
different topics to talk about today and
hopefully i can set this up so i can
actually see what i need to see okay
good
all right first first item styling
elements in grid
yeah this is the most one of our most
kind of um
bizarre
uh
kind of
uh you know
programming
laparoscopic programming in terms of
kinds of activities
um
in my view the the whole way that we
specify
right so you're saying okay so the
question is if i want to put a divider
in here
how do i put dividers
and then style the dividers
uh
the
well the dividers
option um
and i'm not remembering
off top of my head how styling is done
and i'm
looking that up
i think it uses the same sort of
notation that background does
which is very hard to understand yeah
the styling is is is in the
specification of the dividers option
okay the problem that we have
is that
i mean
this whole business about
three goes to red two goes to light blue
oh my gosh
see this is a
column specification i guess
yeah
in that order
yeah if if there were more than one
column specification then that would
have had to have been a sub list
i hate variables like t it's going to
mess up my whole session here
um okay so let's look at this
so you're saying here
well i mean what would happen if i'd
said
three or
one
that's not going to work
for reasons unknown
okay because let me explain something in
graphs i mean i mean is this really
idiomatic
okay so listen listen listen we've got a
number of patterns
that
are sort of similar okay so for example
in graphs with vertex style
it does accept patterns like this
you see what i'm saying
the way vertex style works
and i think there are people here who
know it and use it frequently you give
it a list of
patterns of the form vertex name goes to
style
okay
and
i think that idea
of
specification goes to
styling
you know that's a possible idea for how
to do these in general
if that makes
sense would start with a naming
convention
other than positional
well it might do yes but i mean i think
the problem that we have here is
you know whenever i want to okay so
here's a typical thing i want to do
i've got a grid
i want to style
the top row with a different background
i want to put a separator between the
top row and the net and the subsequent
rows
you know but it's super hard to do that
and i wind up going and looking at
examples of other grids that have
similar things done to them
that making sense so what i'm asking for
is can we invent a way
of um
uh
making
um
well so there are two sorts of ways that
one might go about solving this problem
um
one is to do what you're suggesting
which is language extensions uh and the
other is to
is to make an interface that just allows
you to set the specification the way you
want and then
you know if you need it back in language
form you know have some way to
extract it
and i worry about the language extension
because i already received complaints
that
people
don't
know how it works at present even oh no
they absolutely don't and i don't i like
it
and adding more features doesn't well i
think it was just not very well
definitely simplify it
no i i agree i think but what i think is
there right now is hard very hard to use
and i mean it is along with look
look
go ahead i wouldn't say it's hard to use
it's a little bit inconvenient i would
rather have the dividers as you
mentioned and the background
locally available rather than
like often the kids i make are tens of
thousands of pros and it's and i always
have to find this program that
determines which one to
what to add in the background
that's horrifying
yes
i mean and some of this stuff
it's just really hard i mean
okay
look
i don't even know here
i don't know if i have x rows y rows
okay so look there are there are three
approaches i can imagine
one is scaffolding to make it easier for
people to write correct things by
prompting them essentially with
autocompletes that's one possibility
another possibility is a tool like we
have for images
i have a feeling people will not be
happy with that because so
well and and a fundamental problem is
that
everything is based on counting
you know this is what lou was hinting at
that
you know what happens
uh you know if you really wanted to mark
the content of the fifth row but then
you add a row above it
and now you you have to
you know you have to change all the
references to five to six
yeah right and and and this is very much
a real problem the uh that that massive
table uh that describes precedences for
example in the documentation um
uh
that's really horrible to maintain
because it does exactly that
right
um
let's see
right i i agree so i mean having it be
local is much better having it be a
rapper like this item wrapper is a much
better idea
um
now the other thing is
there are some you know we can imagine
themes for grids
that would also be a possibility but i'm
i'm not sure i mean
you know in the things i've done there's
just so many stupid fiddly things look i
think this needs a kind of another look
at the design
i think we need to think about if we
were doing it from scratch today what
would we do
well we do have and i'm not prepared to
demonstrate this but we do have uh
uh
some
uh
you know a non-trivial attempt at a user
interface for
uh you know for inspecting and modifying
uh great attributes
when was that built
um
it's
it was kind of a background project over
the past couple of years
okay uh but but we were you know we've
been working on iterating enough to
you know we didn't want to bring a
version that was too raw and and
premature to you it's uh you know you
would have just ripped it apart with all
the same criticisms we would have had um
but so okay
let's let's let's just look here i mean
you know the other thing that we could
do which is an even much more
straightforward thing
is you know a pure documentation play to
begin with that is just a giant gallery
of examples
which we surely have even from things
i've done you could pick up a lot of
examples
see what i'm saying so so in other words
that their tables where they're the top
row is differently colored they're
tables where
there are uh you know where there's a
border that's different from the
internal separator separators there's
tables where
the you know the separators from the the
first row but not subsequent rows et
cetera et cetera et cetera are we making
sense
maybe what we should do is try and
collect such exactly what i was looking
for the other day just to comment it's
probably a very common sort of thing for
users to try to do
just get these examples from the
documentation
right
and the documentation is is kind of lame
in this regard
you know because the documentation is
very oh we've got this function and that
you know that functional thing rather
than here is a picture of a of a grid
that looks roughly like this
yeah i had endless trouble figuring out
frames and dividers myself
yeah well so background background
coloring was also not easy having a lot
of examples if we can't explain it
clearly in words then
having a lot of examples will help i
mean if we could explain it better that
would also help right but so what we
could do
i mean i think we've is basically to
have a guide page and possibly even
we could have a style of of
documentation in which we link to the
guide page from here
like that's what we do in in um for
example formats uh import for example
does that
people know what i'm talking about
yeah but i'm not i'm not sure how you're
suggesting applying it in this context
okay so what i'm suggesting is that um
what it does is it just says it says
gallery of of um grid options or
something right here
okay
and then then that goes to a guide page
that is just filled with
different
sizes and shapes of grids
now i admit that that's not quite now
let's see what we do then we then have
to link that to the code for each one of
those things
um
i'm not sure that requires another
design for how to do that
uh
i mean possibly they could be click to
copy i'm not sure
is that obviously wrong
because if you do click to copy there
you know click to copy and the code is a
grid of an iconized generator here
of something rather straightforward like
this
and then what you would do the workflow
that you would use is you click to copy
the thing you put it in a notebook you
see what it does and then you start
tinkering with it
am i making sense
i mean it's
like examples but not examples
do we
yes
to abandon the example model here
i don't think it's working for this and
the reason is
that the examples here are very
sequential
in sections and so on
but we but we could
link to them
i mean we we could have a guide page
like you
uh you know like you're suggesting with
links to specific examples yeah we
should do that i mean that's a fine
thing to do but i think it should also
have a click to copy of some kind so
that you can just use it directly from
the guide page
am i making sense because normally on a
guide page the only thing that's there
as anchors is function names
so the typical workflow is you click
that you go to the function page
and you you know use the function from
the function page
all right this is the documentation to
see but i mean yeah i mean i mean i was
just going to say i mean i can sketch
out the content for such a uh
you know for such a guide page but i i'm
not going to
you know
no we have to separate kind of
visual styling and and all right so we
should talk to brian separately about
that okay but i mean i think the first
thing we need to do
and it's also possible that these
documentation pages are just bad
you know that they were written
when grid was much simpler and they got
added to and they didn't get rebalanced
no no that's it it actually they weren't
written a grid is has never been
much simpler than it is today
it's it's always been maybe this is
complicated maybe this page just wasn't
written uh you know maybe it's just bad
you know because that's having six
examples for styling is just not enough
i mean i've looked at these examples
before it's just not enough
i agree with that
right now now maybe if there were you
know eight pages of examples and i could
just scroll through it and i could i
could see the one i want
yeah and of course you know this this
comes down to the other problem is
you know
if you had
60 examples
you know
you know
just a long stream of 60 examples you
have to scroll through
also has its own presentation issues i
think you'd want subheadings you know
that open
john
so that you could have examples that
emphasize framing or background etc
possibly yes i mean just having one
that's called styling doesn't really cut
it
just as it's just not right it's just
the wrong thing
um
and you know there's spanning elements
we've got one on spanning elements but i
cannot believe that three examples of
spanning elements is enough
actually i mean
in the case of spanning i think it is
yeah actually maybe it is i'm looking at
these and they look
reasonable well
spam from above span from both
all right that one doesn't look bad
look i think the killers are background
which is just freaking incomprehensible
and like like this one where i want it
to be pink and then yellow how do i do
that
do you understand what i'm saying
i want the first
column pink and the other columns yellow
how do i do it yeah yeah um
uh
if you would after the pink you would
add yellow and curly braces
not like that though
no
the one below is repeating pink and
yellow you want a single no no no no no
no that's wrong
you want a single pink and repeating
yellow
so okay so what am i so if i said so
after the pink comma yeah there you go
that's what then i want to end with the
red
uh
right yes that would be the way to do it
that's magnificent if you give me an
example of that i'm i'm off and running
honestly just adding that example would
right there help a lot
i mean maybe the problem we have number
one problem we have is just bad examples
or not enough
examples right like this would have
helped me
you know right there that example would
have helped me
making sense
i mean in fact if we went this you know
uh
if we did this
i will get it from that example what to
do
you see what i'm saying
uh
and i mean i think we need that example
we need another example that goes
up above here
that goes um
you know that allows us to have you know
gray let's say
up at the top
oops
what do i just do wrong
oh i need another close though
right no that's wrong that's not what i
wanted well yeah it that's repeating
gray so if you want just a single gray
yeah there you go okay so that again
this is going to help me because this
example would tell me what to do
we just had too few examples here
let's start up by adding some examples
makes sense i mean that's a super easy
thing to do yeah
we should be able to get that in really
soon and can somebody just
can i just send these uh who can i send
these to
uh well me probably
um
you add it to the agenda i can send it
over to john
well i where am i saving this agenda
it should save
dropbox
it should save itself to dropbox no it
doesn't it doesn't have a hope
what do you what are you saying it
should be it should be um
it should be saved to dropbox or it
should save itself to dropbox
save to dropbox
yeah just hit save
so it's already there
yeah hit replace yep
okay we we need a slightly better
workflow for that but that's not a big
deal
um
okay
all right so let's now just talk for a
second okay so so this helps me i mean i
probably didn't even know this or i did
know it once but you know whatever
right
okay so now
let's say that i want the top row okay
i want to
oh
oh
there's not nothing about dividers here
there's nothing in this table about
dividers there's no information here
about dividers well frames and grid
lines okay is that dividers
oh there's dividers there frames are a
subset of dividers okay so here's what i
want i want to know a real thing that i
want to know as opposed to some toy
is i want
a different kind of divider underneath
the top row
then and there were other pieces right
so so let's imagine that i want some
uh i'm i'm going to say
you know but let me get rid of all of
this no background because i can see
that they're factored i say frame arrow
all okay and i know what that does okay
now i want that
top row to have a different frame
underneath it
i want that line to be different how do
i do it
uh
so
uh for just a line actually instead of
frame i would probably use
dividers
um and uh
let's see i think it would be dividers
arrow
uh
uh
dividers arrow uh list of all comma
or
let's see uh
[Music]
um well i i can take a way to do it
using the
repeating syntax i might say so guys we
already lost the game yeah
i i agree with that but
but it's not it's i mean it's a deeply
non-trivial specification i mean you
have to understand that there's so many
directions you can go here
i know so
i mean you you could say you want you
want all the lines except the one under
the third x in the first row you know uh
no no no no no this is where we have to
do a little bit of a reality check okay
i know from things i've done right there
a very typical thing is you're labeling
the top row you're labeling or you're
labeling maybe the first two rows but
you're labeling you're saying what the
columns are
right and so you want a different
styling for the top row
or you're labeling what the rows are you
want a different styling for the left
column
okay
live stream suggests that what's that
those were both things i wanted to do
the other day and couldn't figure out
the labeling
right
horizontal yeah right so those are very
common things and it's possible that we
should have you know
named you know
named options for those things but let's
cross that bridge later but
but but but in this case the
specification would be if i recall
correctly so
after the all comma
uh open list
uh and then true comma false
comma sublisted true
john i'd like to make two suggestions if
i may
one is if you could come up with a clear
description of what that language means
is this true false etc in terms of
layout
that might be very useful
well i mean i mean it is in the details
section but uh
it was hard this is what i wanted this
isn't what i wanted what i want as i
wanted a thick line now for example oh
oh okay well then you can replace the
false with you know
uh uh absolute thickness of
five or something yeah the other thing i
want to say is one question is do does
grid support the way graphics
two-dimensional graphics does or 3d even
uh
labeling that is outside of the grid
itself but nonetheless useful for
vertical or horizontal axes no it
doesn't no it would be good if it did
that was something could it use the same
syntax
could it use the same syntax
i mean okay so another thing would be
tool um
uh call outs and things in a grid
but look just nailing this stuff would
already be very helpful yes i agree with
that
yeah we already have the all these
capabilities okay so listen i i think
and i'm not sure who should be doing
this but it should definitely not be
john
okay we need to inventory uh
it's possible
one of the
maybe somebody in the special projects
intern crowd could do this
um
the uh inventory
both
for example things i've written
and then other
community posts things like this
types of
you know just look through for the for
the structures of grids people have
produced and then look at what the code
looks like
um because i think we you know danny and
i both
are agreeing that we need to do these
kinds of things so another thing i'd
like to do is to change the styling of
the top row how do i do that
so
the uh
uh
and you know it's i mean there are about
seven or eight options that follow
basically the same pattern here um
okay uh
and
how do i change the styling okay let me
ask this question
it's it's item style it's
okay so if i say false here by the way
that will do that okay good yeah okay so
then i say item style
do item style and background have you
know essentially the same syntax then
yes okay yes uh
the
the tricky part about uh item style is
if you're wanting to con
combine multiple styles i forget
is it just directive or you have to put
in a sub-list that that's the thing that
i don't remember and haven't tried to do
for a long time but if it's just a
simple
you know a you know a singular style
directive then it's it's pretty
straightforward okay listen listen i
think what we need to do let us
inventory
you know things we've written i think
it'll be good to look and see if there
are any style guides out there
for like academic journals things like
that
for tables it would also be useful to
look at for example in spreadsheets and
things like this whether there are
standard formatting
schemes for for tables
um let's do that
and try and make a much larger list of
examples that that can be given here
and and by the way i mean i just want to
be clear i it's i'm you know i'm
conceding your request for examples but
in terms of the you know the narrative
description i think the narrative
description
you know it's necessarily complex
because the specification is complicated
i know the narrative description does
its best to do this i mean look i've
tried to read it a bunch of times i've
had a very hard time reading so so so
what i just showed you was a combination
of the
you know the spec expect y i know i know
the table i understand what it is yeah
and then one of the specifications down
below right i understand what it is
okay it doesn't help me in practice you
know yes i can puzzle through it
eventually although it's much easier for
me to find another example where i've
done something similar and the examples
are awful
here
so you know let's just you know we can
save ourselves a lot of coding work by
just cleaning these up and seeing
whether that's enough
um
that would help a lot if
i i agree i understand what john's
saying that this is very hard to
document
carefully fully and accurately
and yeah and i don't think i think the
legalistic documentation
is not the most important thing here i
think we just need examples what is this
the
i will say if the documentation can be
simplified on these matters and maybe
it's just not possible to make it both
simple and
complete and correct i don't know i i
think it's not terrible as john says i
think what's missing is good examples
okay and lots of them now i mean uh
ethan is is commenting on a live stream
about grid themes
i'm a little bit unconvinced okay i do
not think that graphics themes has been
have been as successful as i might have
hoped
that is
i mean i tend to use the default
and i've never really gone through and i
mean well sometimes i've used weird ones
like like for example people were using
for ages the um
uh some style sheet that was intended
for some very weird purpose that just
happened to look kind of
nice i mean it reminds me of a lot of
these things like pastel or something
like that yeah or something like that
but something more obscure than that i
think
um but it was uh
you know
i have this bad feeling that people
don't
you know sometimes people will find a
particular
you know option setting or you know
particular theme that they like and
they'll just stick with it and that's
fine
but people going and exploring the theme
collection
i don't know what do other people think
about this i mean i found for example
um
when i've tried to look at material
surfaces for 3d graphics a few times
i've looked there at the galleries that
we have and picked one out
um what do other people think about
these gallery based
approaches
to different types of looks for things
like this
anybody want to comment on that nobody
here is relevant i mean right
you know in in general i'm you know i
think the idea of themes
is
you know something that i support
um
in the case of uh
tables
you know it may be that
uh
you know i wonder if we want to do
you know just fixed themes or themes
with parameters well we've got the idea
of themes
yeah
okay that's a different thing that's
that's
a more keyword-based way
of setting the things that we are
describing as completely obscure to set
here
however
in the end
the syntax that we have is not
completely stupid
it's just very hard to remember and see
what to do in a particular case
but once you've got a case like this
given this i can trivially modify this
to the thing i actually want
do you get what i'm saying
yeah
i put a link to
a wfr that many people in the alpha
world like to use
i'm not seeing that link michael i don't
know oh sorry sorry
it was just you ian i had to deform one
to everyone
okay that's an amusing idea from ethan
on our live stream that is an
interesting idea
a a neural net that can take a picture
of a table and generate the style
specifications
that's an amusing idea and probably not
undoable
we should look at that that's an
interesting idea at the very least that
can be a project for this year's summer
school somebody can try and make a
prototype of that
good idea
can somebody make a note of that or
should i do it
up i'm doing it because nobody else said
anything
anybody here who's project managing here
i have it in my notes
i'll do it myself right now
that's a good idea
um but i mean i also
okay we need to figure out and perhaps
not we don't know from this meeting who
can do this
as i said
we need to make sure that somebody goes
and looks at standard style guidelines
for for grids and tables and comes up
with a big long inventory of things that
we need to be able to support
all right did you take a look at
michael's uh link yet i mean no i didn't
i don't have michael's link so the the
no it it he he put it in the chat it's a
nice function
and it references another one by michael
salami that's also pretty good to me it
looks like basically you know a
this is a theme
you know this is one theme bound up in a
function it's is how i would
characterize it
okay what does this do
it has column and row headers and it
delineates the for readability
the background all color
it also has that nice capability of
dealing with missing if you look at the
um
the upper left corner
in cases when it's missing that's a good
thing to have
maybe we already have that i don't know
no we don't
okay look look we've got several steps
here
inventory tables that we want
make more examples
then let's see if there is a new design
for an enhancement to grid for example
we could imagine a headers option to
grid
do you understand what i'm saying
i understand what you're saying um
i'm not ready to comment on it nor am i
right but i'm saying that's an
alternative but we may be able to solve
this just with better examples
am i making sense
do i have to say this i mean yeah we we
know what we need to do
but we need to figure out who is going
to do this because it isn't you john
well i don't have an immediate good
answer i know i i already told you
several answers so i'm expecting that
project management is going to follow up
on this and figure out if necessary
bringing it
you know to the right place to have
these resources found
okay does that make sense
yep
makes sense to me
okay
you can ask brady for his suggestions
but i'm i'm suggesting
uh yeah
i think there's several people who are
possibilities
right well and you know it should be
said i mean there's a certain pattern
here you know if if you start off with
you know whichever option background
uh you know the pattern for
the other options is going to look a lot
like the pattern
for background maybe maybe not because
it could be that the things you want
you know for background right the first
row the last row those kinds of things a
particular row in the middle right how
do you yeah i mean another thing we need
is
referencing you know backgrounding a
particular row like i believe there's an
option here if i say background arrow
none comma gray like this okay and now i
just want
the um the fifth column is there not not
yet another thing here which allows me
to say uh it's uh no it's it's still in
the first argument uh
um really live arrow
okay so then then i go here
five arrow red
okay great
that's fine just show me this example
and we're in good shape yeah you see
what i'm saying then i have some
fighting chance of knowing what the heck
to do
i mean actually you've got to show me
one more thing which is you've got to
show me what to do if i've got five
comma red
you know
seven comma green
i assume i can do this
yes i can
how nice
why did the gray not go on top of those
i
don't
know
what would happen if you put it first
would it matter i can't put it first i
can't believe this because it's
representing row specifications what i
might be able to do is to say none
and then one arrow gray
okay so i don't know why that's
happening
it might be the intensity of colors if
you used light red no no no okay no
so just a question of who wins the
comments it's
well it's no no no it's i i think what
it's doing is it's only
combining the colors from the uh from
the non-rule specification
and then the rule specifications just
uh
overlay or
sorry over over right i should say
okay i'm going to predict that in this
case let's see i'm now now i'm going to
do
none comma
and that will repeat the reds is that
correct correct
you have an extra level of list
really around the whole thing
yeah i thought it would do this so
basically
the specific
sparse array type syntax wins
which is okay that's yeah yeah that does
that's just another way of saying what i
said
yeah that's a perfectly reasonable thing
to have happen but again it's got to
have examples right examples so people
have a fighting chance to understand
this
is there a
you know like a one comma one list
specification yeah that's that would be
the third argument first uh first
argument is column second argument or
first member of the list is
column second member of the list is rows
and then the third member of the list
is uh
the item yeah element specification yeah
got it okay that's beautiful now we're
all learning but we gotta have examples
right totally inadequate set of examples
okay if if really nobody else can do
this i will generate a bunch of examples
this is not difficult
it's just you know and also they have to
be done not too mechanically but just
showing off all the different sort of
orthogonal things that you need
make sense
yeah
okay let's move on to the next item
please okay so i think we've got some
some action here mostly add examples
find standard types of table layouts
make sure those are in the examples
once we see all those standard table
layouts and see the examples maybe
decide that we can do better with the
design
make sense
okay onward
proof graph design
so this is based on the updated version
of proof graph that um nick m had done
and then we have billy here from design
who did a few mock-ups for what that
should ultimately look like okay and
also i gather that nick has now found
the patch that's needed in the
underlying find equation of proof code c
code
to allow
proof functions to work correctly
is that a true statement nick
well that will certainly help yeah
okay
and did you give that to adam and you
get feedback from adam that he can
handle it yeah it's it's already pushed
i think oh great so it's ready for 13 1.
yeah it's it's the small very small
patch that doesn't break anything
and i already
have a prototype of a new proof function
that uses using it
does the proof function have basically
the same stuff inside it or does the
proof function use different
uh proof operations
i mean jonathan's proof function uses
a map at
of replace is that right yeah it's the
same kind of thing there's a bunch of
unnecessary
pattern substitutions like renaming of
variables in there and substitution and
critical polynomials are also working
okay the good news about that is that
after a decade of that project not being
done jonathan went and did it
so the but now it is you know to iterate
on it is not surprising at this point
um
okay all right so what we're doing here
is we're looking at the the nicer colors
and things invented for uh the
mathematics project and applying them to
find equation of proof right
is that correct guys
hello yep that's my understanding billy
maybe if there's more specifically can
you speak up please
oh yeah that was that was also my
understanding as well how the
metamath relates to this
okay so
i don't understand what i mean
you know what we need is the find
equation or proof proof object
and this is a
recoloring of that we are going to have
to provide the legacy one because people
are going to want to still use it
am i making sense
yes
and that that's the dashed one all the
way to the uh side in the mock-up the uh
sort of legacy one
just that one though
yeah
okay
so the main differences here are
i mean what are the different okay wait
wait wait wait wait
was this done by somebody who actually
knows what these things mean or is this
just pure design
gear design
fear design yeah
oh sorry
okay
okay
so we have in mind then
okay so so nick you you need to so the
question is to make less saturated
colors is that the idea here
was that what's being done i don't
understand what's happening here
can somebody explain please
for a dotted
style to represent the dashes uh as it
would be appear in this new metamath
style
i i'm totally confused i'm sorry i'm
totally confused
okay right now okay first of all there
are more nodes here
this has
this is just showing what we would now
call the events and not the tokens is
that true
nick jonathan please
what can somebody explain what's going
on
so
what exactly what was the question okay
the question is we've got proof graphs
okay
we've got the new proposed version of
proof graphs what is the difference
between them
other than colors being changed
my understanding is an addition of
events
explicit events
like unexplicit tokens right these are
are these tokens or are these events
well they kind of both
well but more
okay what is it that we want i mean
these
graphs are nice in their own right
can we please go through what what are
those graphs supposed to be
okay does anybody here know what's going
on with this because if they don't we
can't have this discussion can somebody
explain to me what is the relationship
between this graph and this graph what
are we trying to change what's the story
here
well the simple variation is that you
just add events there and explicit ones
so just an additional a bunch of
additional vertices there
and the new styles
okay okay so so
there are two different things we want
to do we want to restyle the previous
one to use nicer colors
and conceivably change slightly
the uh
you know what what we're doing here okay
the what's dotted what's dashed etc okay
that's one thing the second thing is we
want a style in which we include the
tokens as well as the events is that
right
right
okay so let's let's
okay so let's start off with the
question
all right and then we also have this
version here
in which we are giving the explicit
uh
theorems
generated at each stage
correct
yeah just the same thing just with an
explicit
i understand but we have a very specific
problem which is that you know right now
we have proof graph
which is one of the uh elements here
for
uh a proof object right what we're
proposing here and that proof graph for
compatibility better be something
consistent with this thing yeah
am i making sense
then we need we need things for these as
well right
yeah
just an additional property
yeah i know but we so we do we need
three additional properties or what do
we need here
i guess one and then is enough
and
we don't need one because because we've
got this case here
in which we are not showing events
explicitly
do we want that case or do we not want
that case we show them jesus they're
just tiny
okay then we need some way of
distinguishing between this case in this
case
right how are we going to distinguish
between this case in this case
now we could have some graphics
distinguish them it's just because we've
got to say which one you want
which one do you want but this is just
uh graph options right
which graph option
like a vertex size for event
but we can't give that because we don't
have unless we have a convention unless
we document what the names of the nodes
are so that you can use the vertex
styling functions to determine the
vertex style we don't know how to do
this
right so we could
i don't know what the conventions are
for the actual names of the nodes in a
case like this
jonathan must know what they are if he
remembers
right but but they're just tagged with
expression information and with the
events i don't know at all i'm
it's still unclear to me why it's worth
including events but
okay but but the thing is
in this case
what is the structure of a critical pair
lemma for example does it have a
particular
the the node will just be called
critical pair lemma whatever
okay so if you gave a pattern
[Music]
for
what you would say is vertex style arrow
and then the pattern critical pair lemma
comma blank arrow whatever is that
correct or not yes yes you could restart
that way
okay i'm sure we didn't document that
but but that would
potentially work
okay
so look what we're going to need
okay we're not going to do this in this
meeting okay i think we need
you know nick jonathan
billy
you know to
figure out
you know what we're trying to get is
something that has so
none of these stylings are jonathan's
original version of how this works
right these are both different because
jonathan's version
has
these things
which are
kind of
which is different from this again right
because
in this lemma here in this substitution
lemma
you've got
a
a lemma a theorem from here and a
theorem from here are being combined
and that node there represents the
result of combining this and this
correct
listen listen if we can't say anything
we've got to move on to the next item
okay can you guys please
try and iterate this and come back
because we would really like to get
these changes in but again like i can't
i can't comment on this because it's
still unclear why we're doing it right
so
um
the reason we didn't include you know
substitution event information in the
original design of this is because it
doesn't add any additional information
it makes the graph more complicated and
everything you could have got from that
from including the events you could
reconstruct anyway
um so it's unclear if if there's some
reason to include the events i would
like to know if it's just doing if it's
just to gain
essentially conceptual compatibility
with token event graphs
then
it seems like it should be an option you
know an optional property rather than a
complete redesign i i agree
it's not a completely designed right it
just would be an additional property yes
right i mean look it is for expository
purposes jonathan
you are right that they're unnecessary
right right okay but in that case i'm
going to advocate for the proof guard
for turning the minimal structure
necessary to represent
i think you're right
i think you're right
okay i i just think that the new colors
and things look nicer than these ones
and you know that's all it really comes
down to and we've got but we want to
have the option to produce these better
you know these things which for small
proof graphs are expositorily useful
right and in this case also is exp
expositorily useful for very small proof
graphs
make sense
sure
is there a particular reason why we
removed the um the shape differences
between substitution and critical pair
limits
um
there was for the meta mathematics post
but whether that's a correct thing
for what we
uh
for what we present by default i'm not
at all sure
i think
actually same with the conclusions it
occurs to me
where's the conclusion
the again
we chose the the tombstone symbol for
the conclusion and the triangle symbol
for the critical pair lemma
um like
i remember us having design discussions
about what the right symbols were and
they said i don't know i remember that
too and and we you know
um
the criteria here were a little
different
the criteria here had to do with a
particular exposition that was making
analogies with the physics project the
physics project had not been invented
when we invented you know proof graphs
so
uh look there's one level of this which
is pure color changes and um changes in
the in the coarseness of the dashing and
stuff like this which are pretty trivial
and perhaps for this version that's what
we should do that's all we should do
am i making sense
anybody
okay we gotta move on
let's go on to the next item
okay so you guys need to come back
um
and nick could you please try and
wrangle this and get these folk to no
other nick nick with a c
yep i will
we'll we'll have to talk about it and
try and get a more concrete um follow-up
this was something that was on ice for a
little bit and needs to be taught back
so
you can look at this one this is an
outgrowth of a prior discussion about
looking at our pure math package and
looking at what might be useful this is
kind of related in terms of
having
a graph or network of related
items in our
topology here um since it was kind of
visually similar and along the same
lines as well so what's the question
here
so we're basically trying to inventory
the pure math
package and see what might be useful as
something to extract or there there's a
whole realm of set theory um
applications that is a little more
in-depth that we'll look at as kind of
its own item but this was something that
was kind of similar to
what do we expect okay so this is a
representation of mathematical knowledge
and
you know which
michael maybe can speak to it if ian i
think could speak to you so
so we
one of the entity types that we were
curating was topological spaces like
particular named topological spaces
and we also wanted to know
basically for every single one of these
properties is it true or false
and so down below there was this large
list of axioms that we also curated
that you can use like given some
starting set of assumptions about a
topological space
so this is showing all the consequences
of being a manifold
here
okay so you see in the text box it says
is manifold and so everything that's
green is something that's implied by
being a manifold everything that's red
is everything you know is false
because it's a manifold
and we're deducing these from these
axioms but it was kind of a bespoke
implementation that james mulnix and i
put together
i'm not sure that it actually is
complete but
the
key interesting thing is for that
it became difficult to curate these
topological spaces because
it's just kind of difficult to work with
this graphically and i don't want
programmatic tools to say things like
what is the next property that's like
gives the most information because i had
to check each one of these basically
on paper write a proof myself and be
like yep i checked that this is true
okay so i've got to go through here and
basically i got two i got two comments
about this
there are two
types of
at least two kinds of things that we're
doing that are related to this one is
jonathan's efforts in category theory
another is the whole sparkle query
system
and i would like to understand and is
there anything else that is sort of
related to this
i mean this is a set of
how should we think about this
it's potentially related to what nick is
working on with multi
yes it is also potentially multi might
be a good like if it if i could use
multi to simplify the code for this
well you're saying you might be able to
write this graph
symbolically with a bunch of multis
right so this graph is actually not
showing all of the information about
these the axioms this is showing just
the direct imp
implications that can be deduced from
the axioms
so it's you mean there's a transitive
closure of this graph
can you click the hide deduced button
so
there's now new equivalences because you
had
all of these trues and falses for
different properties so new things
became equivalent new you know now
there's loops there's new implications
so so the graph you see is not a
complete representation of the axioms
and you also can't necessarily tell
which what sense the other axioms here i
mean these are
probably scroll the list underneath this
there i have a column of all of the
axioms that we curated
tell me an example of an axiom here
disconnected implies it's not
disconnected
oh i see that's considered an axiom yes
can somebody maybe jonathan say well how
this relates to category theory if it
does
well i mean i think actually ian brought
up this point in a previous uh ct
discussion but like a lot of the stuff
with the um with the curated topological
spaces data
could in principle be reformulated in
abstract category right so you know
something like uh
you know i know the property uh is
homeomorphism or something can be
reformulated in terms of is isomorphism
in the category top and we can construct
some abstract representation of top so
if nothing else abstract category and
its related functions would give you a
new data structure to represent things
like this and also to do computations
that let you figure out deductions and
stuff
so
i also want to say this is this is like
a
a coarser grained look so we're not
necessarily trying to prove
that for example bi-connected implies
arc connected from like the machinery of
topology i just take that as a given and
what i'm trying to do is for a
particular topological space
uh classify which properties holds for
this space and i'm using this graph
interactively
to try to deduce that
it's kind of like an effective field
theory
yes
well it's kind of interesting with
respect to and we should have asked
james to join us here because he's been
working on the
matter mathematics stuff as i would say
this was yeah
um
okay look
there's also
you know these formalized math systems
like metamath and lean and so on that we
have been trying to understand how they
relate to what we're doing if they do
uh so you know we've got these different
things that are swirling around we've
also got
i don't know how this relates to the
hierarchical entities project and how
that then relates to the sparkle stuff
um if you look at the axioms i think
that
a lot of them are directly translatable
into representations and sparkle like
anne's become
like
class intersections
okay but how does that relate to
our in other words in our hierarchical
entity you know is an astronaut
implies as a person
no actually it's not true there are dog
astronauts
but
you know one could imagine that it was
true
and i also want to be able to say like
you know this class you know if you're
in this if and only if
uh like you might have a conjunction
like an and of an or on one side of an
equivalence
you know
right but so so this is a way
you're effectively saying
um
you know these are various set relations
of various kinds
also unfortunately a lot of these
properties depend on the exact
cardinality of the set in the case of
finite sets and sparkle has some
um representations for cardinality that
this tool just completely can't handle
wait a minute god now we're talking
okay i'm still drop down menu that says
all
yeah can you click that and select
cardinality
click click reset
so these are the cardinality properties
we have and degenerate means exactly one
um but we don't have the ability to say
exactly four
and and take into account things that we
know
that may only hold for
you know i don't understand this at all
i'm sorry i don't understand this at all
what what
okay
okay there's a there's a there's a class
of
of questions
that we confront with hierarchical
entities
which are representations of facts about
the world
that are these kind of set theoretic
facts about the world
you know
all
i'm i'm
you know people have
are
human beings so they're part of they
could inherit species data properties
which could have subject yes exactly
these from yeah right so these are
apology projects
right so these are set theoretic
relations effectively
and we
need to use some of these things for
purposes of um you know one place we
need these is in our hierarchical
entities project
it is remarkable
how long it's taken for us to really
need these things
that is
the vast majority of entity computations
don't involve that kind of um
inclusion
type stuff
it's very reminiscent of units you know
we went for years and you know
spreadsheet programs don't have units
typically and you know one once once
inside computing things
you don't need units
in will from alpha you need units all
the time because you're doing one-shot
computations
we've been able to get away without
having hierarchical entities for a while
but now you know that's part of sort of
completing things is to get hierarchical
densities
so you're saying that this can i think
of this right right ultimately do you
see like i have a comment asserted is
manifold and then deduced and then a
bunch of properties
in in the entity store i was hard coding
all of those with just a comment saying
i deduced these from running the tool
basically but i would really like for
the entity store to just compute those
automatically
yeah this is the ontology
using what ontology using all the axioms
below
and these are more expressive than just
a hierarchy it's okay so so
what you're saying is
in
if if we had logic programming like
capabilities you would be able to do
this deduction right you you've got the
i mean we could i'm sure we can do it
right now
with um
uh you you're given a bunch of these
relations
and then you're asked for all of these
deductions well you need to know
okay typically the typical workflow is
you are given a bunch of assumptions
and then
you're given a deduction that you want
to make and then you find out whether
that deduction holds or not
it is typically not the case that you're
asked what are all deductions that hold
well so the typical workflow is you
start with a
completely blank slate and i i want to
start figuring out what properties a
space has
and so i could have one property
and that'll mean
one one approach is to say there are 100
properties it might have let me check
every single one of them another is more
the entailment cone idea where you just
are going sort of forward deduction you
know which properties does it now have
you see what i'm saying rather than
checking one by one and doing theorem
proving to find out which ones it has
and also like what's the next most
promising one things like that
maybe i mean you know to know
okay look i'm saying in practice that's
exactly what i ran into when trying to
curate was i wanted to know which one of
these is gives the most information if i
were to know the truth value of this
property
right but okay
so
okay so okay i mean for instance what
the thing you're referring to stephen in
logic programming would be encapsulated
by something like alpha lean tap which
is a
you know a hybrid theorem prover proof
checker and theorem explorer
um based on you know mini cameron
fair enough
okay but but i mean so the question for
us is
okay we've now got examples
like these we've now got examples of i
mean most of these things in the past
when they are about sort of common sense
you know people have tried to assemble
these big databases of common sense
facts about the world
uh unfortunately most of them are rather
silly
um and you know it is remarkable how
little we have needed those kinds of
things
for
you know
for what we do and will from alpha and
things like that
uh
what you're showing here is an example
where there is enough depth
of kind of properties implying each
other that it's worthwhile to have some
kind of symbolic programmatic way to
approach it
also also queries like give me example
spaces that have these properties
no i get it but i mean this is a new
thing where we don't have i mean like
like for example let's imagine species
and unfortunately michael had to go but
but we you know it's an imagined species
you know it lays eggs
that implies this or that
you know
unfortunately i think there's a much
thinner
i mean this may be our first example of
a non-trivial kind of collection of
implications that we can then deduce
things from i mean this is this is what
people imagined you know in the in the a
previous generation of ai of expert
systems and things like that people
imagined sort of everything was going to
be encoded this way
and it wasn't terribly successful sorry
if if i might comment just both more
generally and on connections to the ct
framework
um so there are there are two problems
here which kind of ian has just
indicated
and perhaps worth discussing separately
right there's one which is the pure
syntactical proof theoretic problem of
like
what implication you know what can we
deduce from the system of implications
and there's also the model theoretic
question of can we generate examples
that satisfy this particular collection
of properties
um
and both of those things can be i i
wanted to indicate that so essentially
both of these questions can be
reasonably nicely addressed with the ct
framework as it's currently designed
so um
so things about like hierarchical data
structures are essentially encaptured by
forgetful and faithful uh sorry
forgetful and free functors
um so for instance
the fact that you know every every
manifold is a topological space and
every topology is and every topological
space is really just a set isn't
captured by the fact that or
encapsulated by the fact that there's a
forgetful functor from man to top and a
forgetful function from top to set and
so on
and then you you can take the adjoints
of that and you can generate a free
functor from set to top and a free
functor from top to man that generates
sort of the you know the the freely that
creates the freely generated topological
space from a given set or the freely
generated manifold you know
differentiable manifold from a given
topological space or something and then
these kind of more complicated uh
operations involving unions
intersections or ands and ores are
encapsulated by limits and co-limits or
um special cases of limits and co-limits
in the corresponding categories and the
nice thing about that is it both handles
the proof theoretic case because
internally everything is just converted
to equational logic and it's treated as
an ordinary theorem proving problem but
it also handles the model theoretic case
because you can then ask you can request
specific objects that satisfy certain
limiting co-limit equations and and
essentially generate models on the you
know general is represented how are the
models represented
well the models would just be objects
right because if you've got you know
you've you've got some subcategory of of
man that that's been generated by a
collection of function you know a
collection of injection of embedding
functors which is essentially what would
happen if you took you know the class of
differentiable manifolds and then did
some complicated set theoretic
operations on it to reduce it down to
some class of manifolds that satisfy
certain properties and then all you're
asking is just give me an enumeration of
objects in that category
but how do you represent those i mean
unless the information that ian has here
does not contain or does it contain so
so can you do needs of pure math
so the initialization section above that
also has
if you don't have it installed okay
okay
and then do random entity of topological
space
logical space type no just topological
space
why isn't it in the autocomplete the
autocomplete is an actual from alpha
thing yep and then do the property input
form summary grid
and wait a minute no the string input
form summary grid is a property of that
entity
so
we you define the set of elements which
is in this case just the reals
then you define the topology on it
okay
and and these are just symbolic
representations of the topology in terms
of other definitions that are also
curious you know i mean i don't know
maybe i'm
but
it seems like this is good
actual concrete stuff for jonathan's
category theory framework to operate on
am i missing something or is that the
case
well so my point was all of these like
relationships like manifold implies
you know whatever i'm not actually like
proving that in any way from this
representation here this representation
is just symbolic
we can format it in traditional form but
i was just checking tho i was proving
them myself
with pen and paper and then storing it
in a table somewhere manifold is true
for this entity
i was expecting that graph to
help me figure out all of the truth
values
um i understand but what i'm saying is
actually proving from like basically
those representations in terms of like
set builder and stuff
that that's another
that that's even another interesting
application of
uh the category theory framework right
right and so my point is simply that
both cases could be handled right so in
the first instance it i don't think it
would be too difficult to translate
what's been done here
because in a sense all that one would be
doing would be you you generate a purely
symbolic
uh
sort of version of you know of say top
and then um and then you just assert
that essentially a certain class of
functors exists that lets you you know
construct from that particular
subcategories
um
and then you know and and so then in a
sense that all of that could be
generated just purely from the
information that's available here and
then the step after that would be to say
okay then can i provide enough uh
additional equational uh properties to
then be able to not just you know assert
that such a function exists but actually
generate it and prove that it's you know
that it exists and is unique or whatever
um yeah i agree that that's that's a
separate and more difficult problem but
and by the way we have symbolic
representation of a symbolic
representation of top and of a category
end of sets in this project then most of
what we need is already there
okay so i've got a question that just in
terms of thinking about how to
what what other mathematical structures
other than category theory are sort of
competitors for how to represent all
this stuff
i mean this sort of meta information
about
well i don't know what um
can you
i mean something like
lean or the metamath database
are somehow an alternative way to store
this kind of knowledge is that a fair
statement or not
sure except they have more information
because they have
proofs
uh
which this project i see i see i see i
see i see so this is mere assertions
just like for definitions i have the
actual like if you if you want to call
it the implementation like for house
door if you can look up and and it gives
actual conditions for what
that
represent the space being housed but for
theorems we just have
the statement of the theory okay so this
is why jonathan is talking about this so
what this is
is
this is what is true but not why it is
true
mostly
for theorems yeah
like this is a topological space so i
actually define
the set of open sets here
okay
but
but then
with respect to find equation
here
well it's important to note that in lean
and in metamath just as in all practical
theorem improving systems there are
different levels of proof
right like so
you can you you can do theorem proofing
at the essentially the sort of effective
theory level right where you could put
in a collection of implications and then
prove stuff like that and
and a lot of the stuff that's formalized
in lean for instance is of that
character right it's not going down to
base level axioms it's proving stuff
based on some higher level set of
assertions there are also some arguments
that go down you know to underlying
axioms of set theory or topology or
something
um
and i think it's important i mean i
guess you know in um
uh like that
you know for instance in um
wherever it is
if i
uh
pull up my
efforts here with with them
wherever it is like like this this is a
representation of euclid
without any statements about proofs
it's just
just says things like
the these are the propositions in euclid
that are needed to prove such and such a
thing
but it isn't saying how that proof works
is that the analogy to what you're
showing here
you're showing this and this property
implies this and this thing
i think it's the analogy to this and
this is this is what you know you can
like that
that's
the sort of effective level yeah
i think that the the
like
the out component of the graph and the
euclid project and also topological
properties are both examples of
ontologies
yes but this is the detailed
kind of theorem prover level version of
this
and in this particular case a lot more
detail in that graph you still don't
have
a proof anywhere it it these are just
no this one here is just this one
no no this one here is a proof
this is this
unraveled into an actual proof of this
of that conclusion this is merely a
statement of what's true this is the
proof
so you're saying what you've got i don't
think that's true i think these are both
just dependency graphs with different
levels of resolution
but they're still only dependency graphs
of proofs i see what you're saying
you're you're right actually you're
right i have another example somewhere
which actually shows the thing
functions
in geometry
for this particular case because there's
an equational version of
that
right
so
um
okay so
it may be worth mentioning that
precisely the thing that we're
discussing here is the distinction
between synthetic and non-synthetic
mathematics
so um in this duality between you know
logic category theory and type theory
what in type theory would be a sort of
domain specific embedded programming
language
or and in logic would be a kind of
higher level proof calculus in category
theory would be a synthetic would be
what is called synthetic mathematics
like where you're reasoning about
mathematical structures at you know at
the level of topological spaces or
something rather than at the level of
set elements
makes sense well i'm sorry that that's
the thing that you're calling
synthetic as in it is a higher level
that is like this
this is just standard logic terminology
no i understand i understand that so yes
so in synthetic so like
um you know if you want to prove
serums in euclid you could do it by
reducing it to tarsky's axioms and doing
first order logic they're improving
right that would be a conventional way
but there's also the synthetic approach
where you say actually let me produce a
set of axioms that are directly at the
level of
uh you know
geometrical structures and prove things
you know
prove things at that higher level of
abstraction and that would yeah that's
the synthetic approach
and so in a sense the the the stuff in
the that's in the entity store right now
is potentially suitable for a synthetic
theory-improving approach but not
suitable for a kind of
yeah for a non-synthetic atom as well
but but you're saying that we might
still be able to use the same equational
logic theorem proving at the synthetic
level oh absolutely i mean like
obviously it can it can prove first
order implications and you know in
principle you could program in all of
those uh
implicatory dependencies as axioms and
then prove stuff from that so you're
claiming that that ian wouldn't have to
use pen and paper that he should be able
to use essentially the theorem prover to
do the implications in that example so
so
i think that's not quite right i think
that what the graph is doing is what
he's calling the synthetic
reasoning like where i'm giving manifold
cur i'm giving these high level things
and then following consequences from
that
and so so ian am i right in saying that
the thing you used pen and paper for was
primarily in constructing these the set
of implications rather than introducing
their consequences
that that was actually like i have a
concrete definition of the sorghum frey
line and it's like not some finite
object right it's
it it like treat it like i'm doing a
a
homework assignment like prove is the
sorghum flurry line
uh this property or not
so that's like the non-synthetic thing
you have to have a concrete object
that you're working with and checking
the properties of
right
um
i'm gonna have that is what yeah
like
i'm gonna have to go i think there's a
just have theorem statements so i can't
do that part okay
this is very interesting topic it wasn't
what i was expecting in this meeting
um
the uh i would encourage jonathan and
ian to talk about this
and um
and possibly uh
james and nick will also be relevant to
this
and let's see whether you know see
whether this is concrete raw material
for jonathan's stuff
uh
and i i perhaps tony
is also relevant in terms of the
hierarchical entity business
i mean if it's going to be the case that
we're going to wind up with statements
like this about hierarchical entities
like you know animals with fur and stuff
like this
which we've never made use of really
before but maybe finally we are actually
getting to the point where we can use
these things then we should look at this
um and we'll check with michael and tony
about it um go over everyone over here
and see what they think sounds good all
right we need to wrap up here i um okay
see you guys